hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to plague Inc now I love
this game it's been often requested but
I've actually been playing this game for
the past two years on my phone on every
single plane ride to every single
convention I've been tuned if you know
me I've been to a lot of conventions and
I'm really good at it too because I've
beaten every disease on mega brutal I've
beaten every custom scenario on mega
brutal I've done everything and I've
been dying for more on the phone because
I love this game but I've never played
the PC version and to present myself a
challenge I'm just gonna go ahead and
start the game and do it on mega brutal
because I'm pretty confident in myself
although you can probably fast-forward
to the end of the video and you'll see
me weeping like a big bubble blowing man
baby crying about how I thought I was
good but until then I will go forward
and kill the entire world with a smile
on my face and utter confidence in my
loins her is this Shakespeare II and I
have no idea so as I said I've never
played the PC version before I have
nothing unlocked I start with bacteria
which is actually a really easy one to
start with
I have no boosted genes I have no
mutations I have nothing that can help
me on my way but I'm still gonna do mega
brutal because I'm a badass or an idiot
one or the other sudden explosion sudden
penis explosion disease I'm I need help
okay the nipple string okay alright so
with the phone game the only place that
you can start if you actually want to
win was always China but I don't know if
they ever change that
the reason China is because it has a
very big population has over a billion
people it's a huge part of the world and
it's right next to India which is also a
huge part of the world huge population
sectors so with those two you can't win
so I'm gonna assume
the same as before wood interpreter okay
here we go oh boy here we go
I actually have no idea how to edit
things Strangler has infected its first
human we can uh specialize but don't
worry it's nipple strangling Springs
will flow
never mind God weird oh it's so pretty
look at all the graphics way better than
on a stupid phone alright I don't know
if they changed god what is this oh
there's a oh it's the same thing okay
it's the same I forget it's been a while
since I played bacteria I've just been
doing custom scenarios so when some
people play some people try to go
without symptoms for a long time because
they think that they don't want to be
noticed but one of the things that not
many people know is that you have to
increase your severity so you can get
more DNA so the faster you infect the
faster the more obvious your disease is
you need to need to move quickly that's
all you really need to do I forget which
is better which one frickin better I
forget I forget I forget I forget I
think the rat
there we go okay so I choose cysts
because cysts is a super cheap one that
boosts your severity and especially in
the early round it's all about getting
DNA initially the nipple strings are as
horrible oh god the nipples no wait
what'd I miss
there we go oh I'm getting a lot of DNA
you know why cuz it's to paralyze lots
of severity okay so next this is where
the strategy comes in the strategy comes
in just picking how you want your
disease to flow and one of the best ways
is birds birds are great because birds
can fly birds migrate birds go all over
the place birds can actually go to
islands that for some reason birds can
go to islands I don't know I think
that's what it is I don't know what I'm
talking about
ignore me so there's a couple other
things that I could do at this point
actually I could go for more severe
which would be good in that it was in
that it would give me more DNA
especially off the bat so the nipple
strangler has breeding grounds nipples
no yes
give me your delicious disease okay now
we're gonna start transmission vectors I
want that bird I want that bird baby
give me that bird give me the bird give
me the bird give me the bird birdy thank
you because now it's already a little
severe I can actually spread it around
sokka stan has been infected
oh boy it's spread see look at that look
at that spread look at that spread baby
look at that spread oh such good spread
all right now I can stage two birds
I love birds birds are the best oh my
god dammit god stop doing that I try to
double click on things the nipple
Stranglers but you begun
to spread around the world use the world
day to see which countries are not
infected yes
how ominous how ominous of the nips the
nipple Stranglers infected more people
in the world than TB it is a very
infectious disease people not need to
stop eskimo kissing with their nipples
that's one way to stop the spread always
wash your nipples
sneezing wow this is a mutating bastard
I don't need lethality yet but I do want
I need to get on ships I definitely need
to get it on ships Oh
oh god oh god oh god in a normal checkup
a doctor in China found a new disease
which has been naming the nipple
strangler I don't know how I couldn't go
his nipples practically exploded with my
face it appears to be mostly harmless
okay
space pauses because that's what I mean
oh hello England thank you thank you
thank you okay
Wow I have a lot of Danai okay now I
need drug resistance because it's
starting to spread the wealthy countries
so you need that these are very very
valuable early the earlier you get them
because now very soon now they're gonna
start doing research but this like these
have a higher return that earlier you do
it and then you do the genetic reshuffle
so that it breaks it back down again but
you want to do that early and you want
those class four antibiotics because the
super wealthy countries are gonna not go
as quickly as China I know that for a
fact
oh wait oh hell oh god that's a lot of
didn't a way oh [ __ ] I have a lot okay
now I want blue eye on you or do I want
the antibiotics no I think at this point
I might actually be on I might be set to
actually go hard on this one I'm just
gonna do the antibiotics just because I
can and I'm a boss I'm a badass
I'm a bi ass pretty soon I need to
actually go for lethality soon so what
I'll do is I'll walk down pulmonary
fibrosis and the to lethal ones are
right in the center those are the really
lethal ones so oh no no one suspects the
nipple strangler oh there it is okay
that's the Cure progress I knew it was
gonna happen yep
but they're gonna go slow at first cuz
they're spending is oh it's only rank
why oh no you're all gonna die but not
yet because it hasn't turned lethal yet
but I do need to turn lethal very soon
because that's the next stage of DNA the
the next stage of DNA grabbing but you
can't kill too quickly that's the thing
you've we'll see now getting nervous
because I I don't know if I'm actually
doing it right I probably am but
whatever
okay so transmission vectors are fine
I'm sure everyone's gonna be infected
very soon like how much of the world is
okay so the whole eastern or western
western countries need to be infected
it's spreading pretty quickly once it
cuz it's good that it got in South
America or Central America because now I
can spread in both directions and then
push north but I still need to get
Greenland I'm gonna play it safe I'm
gonna go for another boat I'm gonna go
for double water just because I
definitely wanted to actually get to
everybody I've done that before I've
gotten ahead of myself and I've killed
everyone before it actually goes to
places it needs to go alright go trying
to shut down Airport that's why you go
for boats no one shuts down the boats oh
it developed tumors oh god nipple tumors
triggered from my tumor Oh why'd you go
to the same country twice oh there we go
first death oh my god
I know the Nordic countries just got
screwed
oh no there it is there it is okay lots
of bubbles alright so I'm going to we
are at research priority is low I'm
playing it safe oh that's a lot okay so
what I did is I got paranoia insomnia
because that also helps with stopping
people from getting the disease cured
I'm gonna hold off I'm gonna see how
things play I'm gonna Bank oh hey okay
there we go that's good that's good
infected infected infected infected
who's clean who's still clean not many
countries left just greenland is gonna
be a [ __ ] and Madagascar you son of a
[ __ ] if you if you become a problem for
me I'm gonna be very upset very upset
spreading fast
there's Iceland there's that okay New
Zealand got grabbed we're doing okay
look at that it's not bad not bad not
bad Mexico Caribbean still uninfected
nipple strangler on watchlist huh maybe
you should have been watching it a
little sooner than that you know it's
kind of a problem now okay so I
definitely I want this I want it no I
don't want it I want it I don't want it
do I want it I want it I want it okay
yeah because it went from four years to
six years completion so it increased it
by like a lot so okay that's I know I
wanted it more infectious than common
cold Oh No everybody's poor raw nipples
I can't believe what horror be felled
the world in Madagascar already okay all
of African countries hello thank you we
need to start killing people because the
more people alive two hundred and
seventy six days holy hell yeah we need
to start killing people because the more
people alive is not doing well
dysentery yeah there we go
I need insanity I need insanity I do
need that the nipple Stranger killing
very fast wow there wow they are curing
holy hell they are moving fast on that
fricking cure holy [ __ ] my god I still
don't have Madagascar but I did get
Greenland wow they are moving on that
holy hell okay insanity oh okay now
let's see how that did 108 Denver that
doesn't bode well for me oh man
Madagascar got infected okay so now I
just need to infect everybody I need to
be okay
I'm not lethal enough to be too much of
a worry but I have enough for a genetic
reshuffle I'm doing okay okay so only
those countries Morocco and Algeria
they'll get knocked down soon enough so
in fact in fact in fact in fact I know
it's I know it's almost complete on
there oh no not pulmonary fibrosis
okay pulmonary fibrosis that's okay it's
not that it's not that lethal but it is
next to total organ failure which is
very lethal and not exactly what I want
at this point but I got I got two
genetic reshuffles left so I'm fine why
are these countries not infected why are
these countries not info because the
countries next to them aren't very
infected either okay okay and time for
the genetic reshuffle okay come on
total organ failure got oh [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
okay genetic research can take place oh
no oh no no it's killing people faster
than it can infect no damn you total
organ failure oh I didn't want you
III have to get rid of it it's too
lethal that's the thing it's too lethal
oh but I do have enough for another
genetic resale okay hmm huh this is
dicey it's really dicey okay there we go
okay all right pure research done in 105
days get fed get dead get dead yes yes
yes yes
more infectivity more infectivity more
more MORE
give me more give me fuel give me fire
give me that what's that desire
ah [ __ ] okay come on come on come on
come on come on come on yes yes yes die
die die yes yes yes yes yes come on come
on oh no oh no okay now I need to start
killing oh crap
I don't have enough oh I like I don't
know why but I froze up I forgot that I
still have disease points left if I just
like gotten one more lethal thing if it
hadn't evolved total organ failure I
would have been okay because I had to
devolve that I would have rather evolved
something oh damn it
oh man that's so frustrating that's so
frustrating okay alright okay oh that's
so frustrating oh man oh man oh oh
that's so sad
I'm so sad I is so sad
all of my boasting all of my previously
hard-earned skills all mean absolutely
dick in the face of the nipple strangler
okay
I have officially been humbled I'm not
as good as I thought I was then again I
was trying mega brutal without any of
the assistive you know mutations I know
I can do it I just don't have time I'm
literally running out of webcam footage
space right now so if you guys want to
see more in the next episode let me know
and I will beat bacteria and the next
one which is virus on both on mega
brutal without any assistance I know I
can do it it's just like I played wrong
I know I made mistakes I was stupid I
forgot how bacteria works blowing dinner
so I will try it again if you guys want
me to so if you enjoyed this please let
me know in the comments below if you
want to see more let me know that as
well thank you everybody so much for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
[Music]